i'll just take the story that you told
just to kind of complete the since we
mentioned scholarship and that's what i
do
i can plug the scholarship into your
story because the majority of those
people you know that you said they work
for a video game
magazine or whatever some of them did a
lot of them are freelancers
in both cases these people probably
studied something like media studies
especially the freelancers what was the
joke you know we're talking gamergate
was 2014 right
yeah so what was the joke the joke was
um
you know you get a degree in something
like gender studies or media studies or
something and
you're going to be a barista no well
probably you might be but you're also
going to be a freelancer
because you think you're a great writer
and you have great insights so
what are they going to start writing
these sexist racists homophobic blah
blah blah you know keyword
or articles about well they're going to
start infusing that theory and then
various touch points happen in society
that then mainstream it but what's
happening is
these bloggers or freelance journalists
i should say
are essentially starting to infuse that
theory into pop culture
and that theory has been cranking for 50
years saying you know
by the way guys society actually is
secretly fascist it's secretly racist
it's secretly
sexist racism critical race theories
kind of central thesis could be boiled
down to
racism never gets better it just hides
itself better and then you have these
little cutesy
you know graduates and these stupid
degrees become freelance writers and
then it's keyword city right it's
buzzword city racist
video game racist movie racist dr seuss
racist your mom whatever it happens to
be and
uh one thing after another and then
these are the people who are poised to
write these little fluff piece
well they're like it's like the hit
version of a fluff piece right no
content
it's like it's like a it's like a bundle
of thorns or something instead of
fluff but these are the people are going
to write these things and they start
injecting the ideas of systemic racism
and
systemic sexism and all of these kind of
critical theory ideas
into the pop culture through those
mediums and that if you go way back i
mean that was actually gramsci's plan
not to get heavy in theory but antonio
gramsci the
i'm supposed to always say albanian
italian i said that he was italian which
is true
and these uh italian people wrote me
these emails were like call him albanian
italian please
don't stick him tell us don't make it
he was brilliant actually the guy was
probably one of the sharpest minds of
the 20th century unfortunately he was
also a communist
and um he was only realized that you
have to underpin
or under you have to undermine the
pillars of
culture in order to take over a society
and he identified those as being in
religion family media education and law
so that media pillar
that's what the goal was he said what
you have to do is you have to get inside
if you want to take a
pillar of culture down you get inside of
it and you create a counter hegemony
within the existing hegemony and start
making it grow
and basically when you say parasite
that's what you're talking about it's
get
latch on and then grow the strength of
that thing like
like a sith or something i don't know
i'm not a star wars you're the one with
the torches
but um i mean that's the idea right is
to get in there
and to start infusing these critical
ideas this is a plan that's been like
cooking up scholarly for a hundred years
that had actually no real way to work
until all of a sudden we cooked up this
i've been thinking about this a lot
lately in the last
i don't know three months social media
and then i don't know what to call it
but like just kind of like
grubby media you know like you know
little
grubby articles like these different
gawker was like just a
propaganda place or whatever it got
taken down games of telephone articles
that regurgitate the same thing written
by somebody else
grub media called journalism journalism
yeah or urinalism according to jeremy
hanby the quartering today
um you said that the sith were parasitic
i like that because the sith apprentice
parasite off the master grows strong and
then kills the master
i mean there's right there i mean it's
like the whole
plan it's basically you know emperor
palpatine
taking over becoming the chancellor and
everyone cheers for it
i mean there you go but i'm not i'm i'm
convinced
more and more regular people hate all of
this oh totally i would bet i was
talking to somebody the other day about
it
and somebody said the the guy said i
think that we are in the majority and i
was like we're not just in a majority
we're not even in a super majority i bet
it's north of 90 percent
yeah north of 90 of people at best
to the degree that they're aware of it
are annoyed by it or insulted by it i
think it's ridiculous and cowardly
but that's the problem yeah i'll um i'll
get to a point where i have a clear mind
i'll wake up in the morning and i'll put
on like facebook or something
i'll feel like i'm being twisted and
destroyed into
some dark tunnel and i'll have to stop
and put it away and leave
that's why i used to call i mean it's a
formal term that comes out of uh
jacques derrida post modern philosophy
but i used to call twitter a
deconstruction machine
it deconstructs anything you put you put
you know for myself a video of myself
using a sword immediately people add
benny benny hill music and try to make a
joke out of it like
like you can't make a joke out of
something i think is awesome like it's
just not gonna work
like i know i look awesome just shut up
you know somebody changed it into an
eggplant a giant eggplant instead of a
giant sword
i'm like i just downloaded that and like
that's like a meme i share now but yeah
it's fun
but no anything you put on the internet
is going
on twitter on social media i should say
not the internet is going to get uh
i'm so stuck on the german now it's
going to get alph
hoping almost immediately it's going to
get deconstructed it's going to get
taken apart it's going to get
um going to get turned into this
dialectical
soup where it gets chewed up and spit
back at you into broken pieces
like you said that eventually go into
they become the grist that goes into
that
closed circle of garbage media and this
is actually the process
because that crap on twitter becomes the
article that becomes your wikipedia page
right yeah i actually made some food
like this once i have a meat processor
and i put in a nice fine steak and then
i put in some some fish
and some chicken and it became a goop
and then i fed all the goop right back
in
and then i fed all the goop right back
in it became a grayish paste and that's
basically what it is
totally i have no idea what it is but
apparently you're supposed to eat it
it's chicken nuggets
chicken nuggets well i mean it was just
meat medley meat punch
the wikipedia thing though you're
absolutely right dude you know it was on
my wikipedia for a while
like my wiki i have a new it's fairly
new i've only had a wikipedia entry for
a few months and like
right off the bat somebody said like i'm
like my wikipedia said
you know james lindsay portrays himself
as a serious commentator he wrote a book
how to have impossible conversations and
yet he goes on twitter and makes your
mom jokes
that was on my wikipedia yeah and then
that got taken off and then somebody
else i don't know who put it i'm
assuming a fan of mine went on and put
that james lindsay has gigantic balls of
brass
like yeah there you go that was on my
wikipedia for a while like
this you know about wikipedia is the the
the me
i'm i'm actually i've this is probably
bad
in the in the bigger picture but i'm i'm
here for it dude do you know the
zeppelin story
uh for like seven years my wikipedia
claimed that i invented a zeppelin
some kind of autonomous flying camera on
a zeppelin
and it was because i guess there was
some writer who overheard
just like uh uh we were having like a
hackerspace kind of conversation about
crazy ideas
and then somehow they wrote that i
actually invented a zeppelin
and then it that's it it's fact and no
matter how many times i was like bro i
didn't invent a zeppelin man it's like
we're talking about
i bought a consumer drone and me and my
buddy
hacked the drone to broadcast live
footage during occupy wall street
it was like one of the first times i
think maybe the first time there was a
live news broadcast via drone we were
working for a big corporation so it was
just online but it was amazing i was
like flying a drone over this occupy
protest
and then it couldn't fly that long we
talked about a bunch of crazy ideas
and apparently an article came out that
was total bs that wouldn't correct it
and didn't want to correct it because it
was a fun story and then wikipedia was
like tim pool invented a drone and i was
like i didn't and they're like too bad
you're not reliable so you know what
i'm here for it i think i think that was
the tim that was the tim poole blimp is
what that was right yeah or the good tim
blimp
it said zeppelin it said literally said
zeppelin modification or something so so
look tim zepplin
i wanna i want to preserve the the
important cultural institutions that
have helped
bring about civil rights real social
justice
but at this point i think the entire
system it's already falling apart the
gender the jenga tower is in free fall
that's the perfect metaphor
it's these guys are just knocking pegs
out and it's only a matter of time
the thing falls down so you think it's
accelerationism
maybe a little bit but not necessarily
it's very targeted i think i know where
you're
where you're going well here's what i'm
going to say uh
wikipedia is is fundamentally broken
and it it it's it's extremely
susceptible to
attack right now yeah uh but there's
there's a there is a
i wouldn't call it accelerationism but
an opportunity to prove the paradox
well so so here's what happened right i
tweeted impeach the queen we talked
about the other night
and a news guard certified website wrote
an article saying tim poole calls for
the impeachment of queen elizabeth
people supported him saying let's
convene congress like this person who
wrote it
was one of the worst journalists
imaginable didn't understand you can't
impeach the queen
that congress has no power even if you
could to interfere with another
country's monarch
wrote the article and then here's the
best part on wikipedia
they're actually arguing over whether or
not it should be included and for a
while somebody put it in
and they started taking like tim pool
has called you know in in 2021 tim poole
called for the impeachment of queen
elizabeth
and then people are like we have to put
it in and people are like you can't put
it in
and then someone actually linked the
video where i was laughing saying i made
the whole thing up i know
how this system works and i can make a
joke and then wikipedia
must treat it as fact so you have one
faction saying
we know he's basically you know screwing
around and it was a joke tweet there's a
wink
like a wink meme on it and then someone
saying
we don't have the right to choose what
we determine is true or false that's
original research and it's banned on
wikipedia
you have to go by the sources and
newsguard has certified the source
the whole thing is broken that's totally
broken redickypedia that's the name of
this project
what you're working on a project no i'm
just telling you that's the name of your
project read
pediatrics isn't it ridiculous you you
you talk about how twitter and this is
the deconstruction it's like a counter
deconstruction like they want to
build a counter hegemony i want to do a
counter deconstruction so
there's a lot of journalists who will
write whatever you tweet as law
and so if you engage on twitter
seriously and say things that you
actually mean
they'll write articles about what you
say or they'll take things out of
context to make it worse
so as far as i'm concerned i'm all for
biden baby
hundred percent oh who's 2024 go by
i'm tweeting things like you know i
believe in you joe
i treated one hour like if we all cheer
for joe maybe he'll send us the next six
hundred dollars i believe in you
and so at a certain point you have to do
jazz hands for joe well here's the
important thing
all of my tweets are 100 serious that's
it that's all i care about
um i think i think i've crafted
a a strategy that creates a paradox that
cannot be countered in any reasonable
capacity
uh i'm sure there will be attempts but
the ultimate issue is this
i tweeted abolish the atf i tweeted
abolish the irs
which one of those if any are my actual
opinions
i also tweeted you know uh there was a
study saying
that you know fauci says something like
coveted lockdowns
we or they said something like we don't
know if there's ever going to be an end
to the pandemic
and so then i said okay then release all
the restrictions there's actual opinions
in there
which one's the real one maybe you can
come to one of my
you know podcast and try to figure out
how i really feel about things
do i really want to abolish the atf i
said abolishing the police is wrong
what's my real opinion go ahead and
figure it out journalists you won't be
able to which means
any tweet ever used by any publication
from me
will be them publishing complete bunk bs
because you will not be able to
determine which one of my tweets is real
yeah i do this only i change my name
when i do it you know i often change my
name on twitter
so this is inspiring me by the way i got
to change my name on twitter back to
king of your mom so that some journalist
puts out my wikipedia
but he really does think he's the king
of your mom um
but because i am but no i changed my
name though to lames ginzi
lames jinzy is my troublemaking like if
i'm going to say you know
very smart opinions if i'm a virgin
james lindsay is is a deplorable or
something now
and so lames jinzy is my very smart
person persona
um he has all the correct opinions but
but but by doing that you're making sure
they know
which one is the real and which one is
the no no the the the problem here is
that when you change your name it
changes your name on all your rights
so i do it and i make the tweets and
like an hour later it doesn't make any
sense
so then they i have the same paradox i
just
throw a wink and a nod to my uh peeps
that actually pay close attention to me
i'm also going to tweet a lot of nice
things about
lefties good just to be nice
you know but it's really i mean it's my
favorite thing to tweet about lefties is
like
you know is what what the president said
i don't know which president
a president some president said that you
can't hate the
haters and losers you got to love them
because they can't help that they were
born effed up
[Laughter]
it's true i mean it does help even to
win a war
if you love the enemy you'll be better
served at destroying them
you know if you were fighting them i
look at it this way
you know i i was approaching everything
wrong for the longest time i knew
that my word was meaningless for
wikipedia and for these journalists
there was uh like the zeppelin thing
should have been a really
strong wake-up call for me no matter how
many times i kept screaming i didn't
make a zeppelin people were like the
guardian i think was the guardian that
wrote it so like
shut up you're not allowed and so it's
like okay why don't i just give
ridiculous quotes to journalists and let
them write things and then have that be
could you imagine the historical record
i did that to zach beauchamp whenever he
interviewed me about the grievance
studies affair he called me and it was
like the most leading conversation ever
he was like wow that's very interesting
i learned something new i had no idea
that was true
could you tell me a lot more about that
you know and i was like
i'm just gonna plant quotes and see what
he see what he publishes
and he wrote the best article ever i
love it i mean it terrible it's
it's awful to me but it's so funny
because i know what i said and i know
what i was like nonsense he published
things i wanted him to publish right so
i owned him and he doesn't even
to this day he has no idea that i
absolutely item on that article i think
there's two things people can do they
don't realize
become active on wikipedia and then
the interesting thing was watching
people on wikipedia who are like
they have legitimate accounts and their
long-standing editors are going over the
philosophy and merits and the rules of
wikipedia and it just be becomes
absolute it's it's bedlam
like you can't use original research but
tim poole admitted it i don't care if he
admitted it and they're just fighting
yeah this is what you're gonna do
because i mean it reduces wikipedia to
absurdum like
it's not even like it's an unreliable
source like all your college professors
might have told you
or your high school teachers or whoever
it's like it's actually
it's actually just reduced to absurdity
yep yeah my one of my favorite things is
that like i haven't taken twitter
seriously in a really long time
oh no that's that's key you can't take
too i mean the second you take twitter
seriously you're doing it wrong all
these people are mad at me like what are
you doing on twitter i'm like having fun
it's like a sewer pipe like as fun as a
sewer pipe i mean it's not like
that's what i used to say it says
information out which may be the form of
whatever you want to send through
it was a sewer that followed you back in
the day but my other buddy said no it's
more like a dumpster fire you pack up in
a backpack and take with you and i
thought that was the best way to just go
with you right
accelerationism i think is the wrong is
the wrong idea typically people use it
to refer to like physical chaos and
violence and stuff
but i think like screwing with the press
to
prove the the failures and the paradox
of these systems i wouldn't call that
accelerationism i would i would call
that like
it's almost like sabotage it's almost
like well it is
you can sabotage can be a form of
acceleration like if a dam is cracking
and you're like dude that dam is going
to break and kill
millions of people so you go and you
smash the dam
you accelerate what's going to happen
anyway because you're like let's just
get it over with well so
you're the one that's blamed for
destroying the damage i'm not talking
about
what i'm talking about is so long as the
media goes unchecked
it will not be a dam that's about to
break it will last forever and it will
grow and they make lots of money i think
it has to break eventually don't you
no crazy culture or war nothing i mean
until they drive people to kill each
other
my usual answer with that is the truth
is always going to win in the end
right so it will break but the soviet
union lasted 70 years
i don't think that's a long time of such
i don't think the truth is last i think
the winner of the war writes the history
i mean reality is still going to bat
last you could the lie only maintains so
long and what if whether you know what
actually happened or not is a different
question
but the the the damn which i i'm
thinking of it as
as the ability to continue maintaining
the lie
um that will give and
it will eventually the truth will out
and but the problem
is is that you know a like i said the
the soviet union lasted 70 years of not
that good
to put it mildly and the china is still
going yeah
um it's been a long time it's still not
great
and uh simultaneously you know when
you're talking about something like a
cultural revolution which is frankly
what we're in the midst of
accelerationism can push people like
you're talking about a dam breaking and
millions of people dying
yes tens of millions of people died in
the cultural revolution you are correct
and accelerating toward that rather than
trying to figure out a way to divert the
course of the river
um is probably not the best strategy i
have an analogy
it's like you're in a car right and
you're like on a on an abandoned
train track and you can see that up
ahead the bridge is out
and if you try and slow down you might
just go off the cliff but if you slam
that gas baby you could jump the gorge
and then
or reach what 88 miles an hour that's
what i'm gonna say you gotta hit 88
miles per hour and then
back in time when the bridge was still
there yeah yeah no no forward in time
when the bridge was completely even
better but you need to have like a plane
actually that's a really interesting
that in back to the future the bridge
wasn't there yet and they hit 88 and
then
hit the future where the bridge did
exist and it wasn't about going super
fast it was just the right
speed so nobody died there was no
destruction
so perhaps if we if oh no the train went
off though and blew up you're right
there was some destruction so maybe the
train was blowing up anyway because that
crazy chemist put those um
pink logs in there that were blowing its
gaskets and stuff right so wait wait
great so so here's the announcement 21
gigawatts we're all in the woke train
and if we don't get it to the right
speed the delorean won't make it to the
future where the bridge is complete and
we can all live peacefully
but the woke train is going to go off no
matter what that's correct
actually i think that's a good one that
was like pop culture reference
i was like this is going right off the
gorge the whole no and then it landed
you landed that tim
these these there's a lot of progressive
pundits get really triggered by by pop
culture references
yeah i'm like you know like you don't
have to like it i don't care probably a
lot of people might not like it one
point
21 gigawatts well right regular people
understand pop culture and it's
interesting to me who are these
progressives who like don't watch movies
and don't watch tv shows and like are
not part of culture
maybe that's why they're in this weird
space where they believe these weird
things
uh they're sad
how fun is it talk about back to the
future it was way better great movie
totally it was fun
that was christopher that was three
three was great well that's the thing
he's incredible he's good hey do you
okay so we're talking about
accelerationism the cancel
the culture war do you think that it's
like a chinese or a communist
intentional plot to subvert the
political structure one of
many that this guy what was the guy's
name the albanian guy oh antonio gramsci
this communist
conceptual artist antonio gramsci
gramsci
um do you think they're using that
philosophy now to try and undercut
american society
um yes and no more yes than no
the infiltration of the institutions and
the establishment of a counter-hegemony
and a counter-state
which the peeps in the on the right call
a deep state
is certainly something that's been an
objective uh
that's been explicit by the radical left
intelligentsia
it was definitely adopted by big players
like herbert marcus in the 1960s and
you're like
who he was a rock star he had huge
followings you're talking 1960s and he
could
like he pack a house at 300 000 you know
sales of his book in the first like
couple of years that came out or
something in the 60s
so this is a he was a rock star on the
left he was mentored to angela davis
we're talking about blm and
wow prison stuff he was he was her phd
mentor at ucsd
and so it's like he's not a french
figure
and he deliberately said in the 1960s
that it's time for the leftist
intelligentsia in the universities to
start teaming up with the cultural
outsiders
and the racial minorities specifically
to form
kind of a block that would operate in a
in kind of unison
by the racial minorities who didn't of
course mean racial minorities what he
meant was the radicalizable
black liberationists who were operating
within his paradigm which was the
paradigm that was identified
by the communist party in the 20s and
30s as the wedge issue that would open
america
so there is an element to where it's
very deliberate now your typical woke
person
never heard of any of this has no idea
they're just trying to be a good person
they put their black square on their
instagram
they're like but i do care about racism
and they have no idea about any of it
your typical
professor of gender studies probably has
a dim idea at best maybe hasn't even
ever heard of gramsci
so um probably has no idea that this
actually was a communist plot although
they're going to still say you know down
with capitalism down with capitalism
on my flight in here i was actually
reading herbert marcus's
essay on liberation which was written in
1969
and he's just like all through it he's
like
you know what we have to do is abolish
capitalism in order to make room for
socialism so this was certainly
something that was in
that line of thought all the way back
you know in the 60s and was deliberately
implanted into the
the scholarly literature uh very in
the universities very intentionally then
so there is an intentional aspect to it
um it's also modeled after what we are
experiencing as a cultural revolution
you know you brought up china
the chinese had a cultural revolution
the 66 through 76 or 65 through 75 or
something like that
um it was pa the wave for that was paved
i know mao was his own special kind of
character but the way for that was paved
with the same
rhetoric as we see in critical race
theory applied to the han race instead
of the white race
talked about han supremacy starting in
the 1920s in china started talking about
some people were good hans and some
people were han supremacists
like separating all the rhetoric mirrors
really closely exactly was going on and
they started to create basically racial
disharmony
throughout china and then that was kind
of part of the grounds upon which that
instability
that mao was able to step in who
when you say though is your typical
critical race theorist a marxist well
some of them are i mean you had the
founders of black lives matter come out
and say you know we're trained marxists
they got caught on video saying that
was that patricia collins i don't think
they were caught on saying i think
they're proudly saying well i know they
probably was like a public thing
yeah i mean it's it's def and if you
read their website before they scrubbed
it it was like comrades this
black lives matter fist is actually just
the communist fist right
yeah so not even the black lives matter
fest but people call it that right
i mean that's exactly right it is it is
just a communist fist
um so there's something very deliberate
there
but again your average critical race
theorists may not know very much of this
because they're just caught up in the
theory
uh just going along with the theory so
there's like this lack of intentionality
but then you say
who's funding this who's dumping the of
course the universities are giving it
space but who's funding this and you
start looking at the various you know
huge organizations that are funding this
throwing billions of dollars into it
uh you have for example kimberly
crenshaw is one of the crew she is the
creator of intersectionality she was one
of the creators
of critical race theory she was a she
cites
angela davis who we just mentioned as a
student of marcusa
well she runs this thing called the
african-american poly policy forum
that's almost completely funded by the
open
society foundation this is one of these
big billionaire philanthropists that's
basically dumping money into this that's
a george soros that's soros yeah
what's the agenda there it was he a
communist well i don't know
i have no idea mackenzie bezos also put
two billion dollars into critical theory
yeah i mean tons of them i mean the the
oregon ethnic studies ethnic math
program that just made headlines
everywhere where they were like focusing
on the right answer is white supremacy
culture
two plus two is five two plus two that
one's not in there but it's
it's in the wheelhouse yeah but
ethnomathematics for the state of oregon
which just got pushed
through by law i think into their
schools that's funded by bill and
melinda gates
the whole program was funded by the bill
melinda gates foundation
and so it's like there are are they is
bill and melinda are
they communists i mean it's like i don't
know i don't think so maybe
um i don't know thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you